hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play real horror
stories to tell in the darkness does
anybody remember those books or scary
stories to tell in the dark you know
those were one of my favorite books back
then but they changed the illustration
in the most recent release because they
scared kids I'm like what the hell what
are you gonna do okay this is totally
not related to anything that we're doing
right now so we are playing a new horror
flash game here and I'm gonna click this
button here so that we can see what is
waiting for us in the darkness stories
tell of the dark forest many lives have
been lost there you are now at the
entrance of terror
do you dare enter aren't you afraid of
death nope I don't dare I don't dare
enter actually if you can tell it's even
darker in my apartment than it usually
is because I turned off the side light
over here so it's like pitch-black
if I turn it around and there's only
this light on my face and that kind of
makes me blind so when I turn around
it's just pitch blackness it's really
good let's do this I'm eager and wait oh
well that's a good start the trees
dripping blood and I haven't even
stepped two feet into the forest and
what was that noise okay good jiggly
jiggly something gonna follow the tree
something's up there I'm gonna make it
fall down okay Chiquita
oh hello alright that's a light okay
there's a drippy droppy bloody on the
ground there's a lady lady house in the
tree walking through the woods oh there
we go finally got that sucker down what
is that a doll yeah that's normal
okay is there anything else that I need
to click okay turn that out basically on
these sort of games you just kind of
click around until you find the magical
thing that needs to be interacted with
at the time
so that takes
hey old lady are you doing good
okay this is duygu to be fun oh lordy by
the way if you guys aren't putting on
headphones and playing this is playing
this video in the dark it's not the same
so basically you just kind of repeat
clicking on everything until hi how are
you doing just go out for a jog in the
middle of the woods in the middle of the
night okey-dokey
like me some light again no thank you
oh I want it my light why did it explode
why would that happen where's that come
from okey-dokey
yeah that's normal it's gonna change
isn't it okay flaky flaky
ricky-ricky what's gonna hi it's that
same jogger he's he's fast he looped
around the whole park good for him
have you changed yet yeah okay go away
please
thank you I don't want any hey welcome
back
hi oh not you stop it lady where you
cried my grand lady cuz you're old and
ugly and no one loves you is that why
cuz you're alone in a forest because I'm
sorry lady are you okay oh maybe I mean
just give me what I'm secure sad touch
your feet what's with the blood why are
you crying
answer my questions and then I'll let
you go
please now children giggling around me I
do not like the giggling sound of
children anything I'm running out of
things to click here oh we're having a
happy fun time in the woods here oh okay
still waiting on something to click
there you hi little girl
are you the same little girl from the
picture because I don't want anything
hey look it's jogger again hi doggie hi
hi little girl
you doing okay you want me to push you
on the swings yep he's closer okay okay
like the Pillsbury Dough Boy hey what is
it lady lady okay oh wait a minute
hi lady
are you done crying now are you gonna
jump in me Oh Oh why'd you have to
explode oh oh that's like my work that's
like go oh I hate when that happens in
movies and I guess real life too but oh
that's like the worst way to die a
pregnant woman hacked to death killer
unknown okay yeah that's good
oh wait you decorated the place yeah I
don't think I can save I don't think
it'll let me save
[Music]
this game I'm trying to click I'm
clicking I'm clicking as hard as I can
save but I don't think anything could
see me now
uh why did I go into the woods again why
did I go I mean there if I wanted to
kill myself there are easier ways to do
it than eternal damnation in though oh
great
once again go right into the thick of it
is that a candle Oh
Spidey's dead bodies
yeah post a dead body with your hand
just touch it Bruce my air conditioner
just blew air on my neck
I'm sweating right now by the by oh I'm
not doing well Oaks is a dead body
okie dokie who's that that a dildo dildo
in there dildo candle hi jogger how you
doing give me my candle you're just
gonna come out and bought my candle each
time you're gonna be that kind of a
douche well there we go again I'm trying
to get some cheer in here oh it didn't
show oh there he goes delayed reaction
well screw you too okay so I got a just
light it enough that he doesn't come
rushed before he might poke the body
until something happens right and there
he goes again
dick why there's a skull in there is
that important
okay come on
oh I got all three ah you didn't get it
that time you doggy bastard
Oh something's happening with that that
doesn't look good
that's not good I shouldn't keep poking
I prize I really shouldn't hi Spidey
you're big they look a star under Graham
thingy okay seriously again I must ask
why I am poking a dead body in the
middle of the woods but then again not
the strangest thing that's happened hi
okay body is gone I don't know if it
exploded I wasn't looking my eyes were a
little closed Hey now what got in my
chest
ready okay don't do that ever again
five demon dancing around in a circle
with a star not a stupid okay
alright then alright then okay so what
so what about that funny
Oh what uh what happened what happened
what happened what did I do
what what oh oh oh something happened
wasn't really paying attention I think I
took the blood and I I did something
with it what did i do what did I do
aha
come on do it do it no okay guys start
over start over okay just I got a hold
down the mouse button that's it oh man
that was tricky that was actually pretty
tricky because no mechanics prior to
that that made me click and drag though
alright there's something gonna jump out
of me again okay good job everybody we
did it we're going in the cave because
for some reason were a psycho crazy
bastard and something moves by me or is
something behind you
[Music]
[Music]
I brought don't even look creepy there
hi hi how's it going my friend my friend
Oh
foon da bah another sultry and sensual
evening of not here desire yes hope for
that body again cuz that's what I do I'm
a serial dead body poker okay other than
that what else is here ah some bats
always good banging on the skull just
bang it on the school come on out
birdies that's not birdies for a bats or
not Birds
don't don't don't don't don't don't
don't anything anything anything hey
it's that jogging guy hi welcome back I
was wondering what happened to you I
wouldn't want anything to happen to you
out in those woods it's dangerous I
can't stop it
I don't love it let me poke my dead body
you go away please
no thank you okay he's out of that body
a-bore so I'm not gonna poke him I don't
like poking everything oh he's dead body
now I could go back to poking him hey
that was a fat jog oh hi
I see you oh they don't like what's in
there so I'm not gonna like what's in
there anymore was that my doom oh no
still moving forward hello dad oh you're
not dead
I won't poke you as much I'm not
interested in live bodies just the dead
ones
I got Tracy thing and the thing with the
thing and the thing I don't know I don't
know I don't I don't want to play I
don't want to play I don't want to play
play I don't want to play what am i
doing what am i doing I don't know just
clicking randomly until something
happens
dumb thing okay there seems to be
nothing happening which means I can go
home we spoke too soon goody goody
gumdrops I found the last clickable
thing in the room okay so about that we
got that oh hi what the hell are you
you're breathing that's not a good thing
which means you're alive Cthulhu Cthulhu
I'm just summoning uh-oh
hey are you that old lady no you blew up
who are you then
[ __ ] you hi okay
the constant jump scares are staggered
us nah okay magic are you cool with me
just being here cool with me just
watching you
ah come on stop that ha ha ha ah since
I'm already a murdering cycle I'm just
like hey cut it out you hey stop that
leave him alone oh look he's gone well
alright then anything else I can click
anything else what else what else can
you throw at me what else what else what
could you possibly summon that would be
worse oh you're not some of the anything
you're sucking me into hell good I was
getting tired of this place okay
I must be some kind of special if
they're gone through the all this
trouble to get me some oh there's more
there's more
there's even more all right it's gotta
get in the jump stairs the constant
similar jump scares are starting to get
a little old I wish it would stop that
other than that is like phenomenal I
like it but they use the same jump skier
thing every single time it's getting old
so other that I really like it oh I am
in hell and look it's a pope that exists
as a zombie Pope zombie Jesus here to
somewhere Raptor Jesus Tommy Jesus
reference all that good stuff so I
started out just taking a walk in the
woods and for no apparent reason I I
just decided to go into these haunted
woods and then I just decided this is
weird
but I wonder if it can get weirder I'll
just keep going I mean what's the worst
that can happen
oh wait I'm in Hell oh okay well better
keep going then hey at least the joggers
still here with me as gang only it's the
exact same sound well he was a zombie
Pope I don't know what he was crying
about probably didn't even affect him
all that badly did he get this guy - he
was looking at me funny nibble on that
guy what's going on what got out with
that guy what's going on hey why's he
just dancing everybody dance dance okay
I hate that oh I hate that I hate it
when people burst from the inside out
that's
okay yeah I get it I get it the jump
scare noise I'm in hell
how much worse could it get I mean
really uh hi hi hi
friend oh really dun dun hi I'm poking
your door do you not like me pokin your
door I'm gonna poke it again I swear I
swear to God
hahahaha yeah okay yeah stop eyeballing
me on how that jogger took care of you
you were just you didn't even know the
jogger was all over you joggers got my
back the joggers got my back now I know
I'm going into hell because this jogger
has been taking care of everything for
me I mean he played a little prank on me
with that Alma it's so hot dude played a
prank trying to put out that candle for
me but he's been doing a good job
protect me hi floating skull yeah I
think things have gotten significantly
less scary like as I started going in
and the woods was fine they should have
ended it after I went in the cave there
they should have ended it there like in
the cave I found something and then I
died what yeah I'm totally out of it
though I was I was totally immersed in
the bee and he was amazing I loved every
second of it but right now I'm just is
this Simon Says hell addiction I bet it
is I bet it is it's Simon Says hell
edition ha ha it is it Simon yay oh boy
oh [ __ ] I am
oh man everyone's gonna think I'm so
dumb I wasn't paying attention I was too
busy big cavitary stupid joke it was our
that was the double okay I'm sorry
I'm not that stupid that one looks like
[ __ ] and balls just pointed that out the
penis balls okay last one boo
oh hey look at that I got it on the
first try
I'm amazing totally didn't take way
longer than was necessary I'm the best
seriously my short-term memory is not
very good I can't even remember some of
my friends names like seriously I knew
this guy for three years as a with
Patrick and I go up to him and I'm like
hey pardner yeah yeah sure sure I do a
partner ozox I really couldn't remember
his name I'm so bad things like hello
buddy how you do
you don't sound too good does it where
does it hurt does it hurt okay alright
or her stare does it hurt okay I
understand all right all right all right
just calm down we'll get you situated
my Dubai assistant will be through here
normally and we we can do does it hurt
here okay okay good good good career yes
yes we already covered that and here
sure babe
you didn't pay Harden assistant can you
help me out here
nurse nurse Wow a nurse you never have
your nurse excuse me you're gonna have
to wait in line I'm a very patient
doctor in hell you know how many cases I
have here oh I don't have time for the
etheral tendrils puse who cares about
boosts ode shoes choose one choosing my
HMO choose choose what okay left right
left right left right left right
eeny meeny miny moe catch a tiger by the
toe if he hollers let him go eeny Meeny
I forget the rest of the thing but my
name is markiplier and I am the best
oh man this can't be the right choice
this seems stupid hey wait where'd that
disappear where's my jogging buddy nurse
are you nurse you are alive you escape
the tormenting agony of hell all those
horrible nightmares and monstrous
creations are now only about a memory
but you can you rest now knowing that
shadows and spirits are out there
perhaps something out there will get you
eventually I can only hope so
well now is there everybody thank you
all so much for watching I'm not ending
it there though I have to say I have a
few things to say about this it started
out great but it overstated its welcome
and it took itself down a road where it
tried to make sense of things and that
was where it went wrong when it tried to
make sense of itself when everything
didn't make sense and there was supposed
to be this in a mystery to it that's
when things went wrong things got really
really disconnected really quickly
especially when you went into hell
because in my mind I'm like why would
you even go into hell there's no way you
go from forest to randomly finding this
grave opening a cave and then going in
hell there is some realism that has to
happen in hoar even if it doesn't make
sense at first it has to be based in
something that people understand in some
semblance of reality so there was a huge
disconnect at that point they should
have ended it in that cave where there
was a sacrifice danger because I would
have perfectly understood that there was
a sacrificial chamber and all that and
everything up leading to that was
fantastic I was totally scared out of my
mind but as you guys saw I quickly
became unscared very very quickly like
it was sudden jarring because I got
stuck at that puzzle and that made me
have to stop and just think about what I
was doing whereas everything else was
just flowing for me and I had to like
focus on the task at hand and and it
completely threw everything off because
I was stuck there for like good 3 or 4
minutes doing nothing and totally broke
my concentration but it was still great
in the beginning so I have to recommend
it so guys play it for yourself in a
darkroom headphones to crank up the
volume see how you fare if you like it
better than I did so
thank you everybody so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos it
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]
ladies